everyone for care about everyone they're
gonna die
places on earth x2 night crossover event
starts Monday November 27th on the CW
the first time events will align that
give team flash a chance to discover
your identity this is earlier than you
anticipated like hell you know it's at
risk I'm so 4:06 When Harry Met Harry
how is our search for the mysterious
DeVoe coming fantastic the team is
trying to figure out who the bow is and
they don't really have much to go off of
we need more help maybe I should call my
friends here what I think he's being
sarcastic hey Harry all your friends are
in this room what the team doesn't
realize is he's just gathering out the
Council of himselves
so what Harry learns is that it's not
just other people that he doesn't like
so much this was a bad idea
he doesn't like himself that much either
and none of them can really get along
and it's really up the Cisco to sort of
get the team or the council to work
together so they can figure out who that
is you stretch it stretches and you
squish Ralph now that he's a superhero
he really wants to have his own suit and
Cisco surprises him by giving the first
version what is this a puppy the
raincoat
at first glance doesn't look like it
would quite fit him but you know as he's
elongated man it stretches into the
form-fitting suit that is really
unflattering this meta has the ability
to leave a psychic imprint on objects we
also in 406 we introduce black bison and
black bison has the ability to bring
effigies to wife so that becomes a
little difficult for flash and Ralph you
let her get away we could caught her out
the episode Barry has to teach him the
lesson that it's more important to save
people than to catch the bad guy if the
makings of the hero hey everybody so I'm
back from the Justice League premiere so
let's break down this four-way crossover
teaser everyone you love everyone you
care about is going to die we finally
got a look at Earth X Prometheus we
finally got a look at Nazi Oliver we got
a better look inside that wedding at
some of the other characters getting the
crap blown out of them by the earth X
team up so the teaser raises more
questions than it answers but it does
give us a better look at some of the
other things that are going on so
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so I know a lot of
you are already talking about characters
that might be dying during the four
night crossover like there might be more
than one character because we know that
Captain Cold is like leaving the role of
Captain colds so they might give him an
out by killing him but there's a lot of
people that think that Felicity might
die obviously I don't think they're
going to kill our felicity because we've
already seen her filming episodes past
the crossover so she's totally fine so
it sounds like they might wind up
killing earth x felicity either before
the crossover and it's sort of like the
prequel that leads Nazi Oliver to go
crazy or it has something to do with
setting off the events of the crossover
but these pictures are the boots walking
through STAR Labs is just another
picture of our heroes walking to breach
two earth X then you have Prometheus
opening the doors here and what looks
like STAR Labs like the way they cut
this is very misleading so you don't
know which building he's inside of but I
believe they said the Josh Segarra is
not coming back so earth X Prometheus I
think is supposed to be a different
character so that could be Tommy that
could be somebody else I think the idea
of what Prometheus stands for is a
reckoning for one of the characters but
I don't think that he's simply going
after earth decks Oliver he's coming
after one of our heroes like our version
of Oliver for some reason too so it's
still wide open to theory crafting I
think the idea is is that some of the
emotional turns that they were teasing a
couple months ago is that some of like
the really dear characters to us are
actually dead on earth acts through the
actions of some of the other people on
earth X and maybe they find a way to
blame what happened on our heroes
because there's a Speed Force storm in
the trailer here I don't know why they
would have put that in there because
that's footage from the end of season 3
on the flash so what does that have to
do with what's going on on earth X
unless this is also something that
happened on earth X we'll find out it's
just weird when you find old footage
from other unrelated episodes showing up
in your big four night crossover teaser
random picture of Barry staring at
something
another stormtrooper a bunch of them
that look like they're getting ready to
kill a bunch of people on earth X I
think the idea is is that everything
that looks like it's on fire is on earth
Dec so like any time it looks like
something is going crazy in the
background
where they are with the exception of the
wedding on our earth you get another
great reaction shot from Joe just like
what the hell maybe he's looking at
Supergirl because he's staring up in the
air you have Cisco and then Katelyn
getting the crap blown out of them this
just looks like them being ambushed at
their first attempt at the wedding like
they try to have the wedding in the
normal way there's actually pictures of
iris in her wedding gown
then they get ambushed and then they try
to have the wedding again much much
later because a lot of you have probably
seen them being married on the
beachfront it's a much smaller affair so
that looks like it happens after they
solve everything like okay let's try
this wedding again only now we'll just
do it in a much simpler way but let me
know what you think of the idea of not
see Oliver and I know everybody's asking
about evil Barry but I think the whole
idea here is that the reverse-flash of
the crossover is Harrison wells so I'm
not expecting to see an actual evil
version of Barry because we just did
that during season 3 so I don't think
they want to be redundant in what might
end up happening is that he might be
dead along with Earth X iris because you
know maybe they were in love on Earth X
but because it's Nazis they wouldn't
look too kindly on the color of irises
skin so she might be dead or in a
concentration camp somewhere so just
imagine if there were people that the
Nazis would have gone after during World
War two and really hated they also
probably hated those people who were
like the characters on our teams so
that's why we might not see every single
alternate version of the characters then
not to be forgotten we have all the
council of wealth stuff that's happening
tonight so obviously they're introducing
black bison like they said so you have
sort of the elongated man Barry plot
going on on one side of things where
he's like slowly trying to teach him
that just because you can catch the bad
guy doesn't mean that you should not
save the people that need to be saved so
sometimes the path of the hero means
allowing the villain to get away so that
you can do some greater good
so we've seen Barry do that in the past
before like he's had opportunities to
kill the reverse-flash in previous
seasons but he doesn't because a true
hero tries to see the good and everyone
it always considers everything that's
happening in the moment not just their
initial goal of taking the villain down
so that'll be fun I know everybody's
still waiting for soo did Neetu
come along like I think that we hope
that Ralph is still kind of a dirtbag by
the end of the season but he slowly
meets her in the back half of the season
and she sort of turns him around a
little bit like he learns to be a hero
with Barry but it's really sooo didney
that pushes him over that hero ledge so
just everybody keep your eyes peeled for
a character named sue to pop up during
elongated man's storyline and then
obviously the Council of Wells is gonna
be nuts so it'll be fun to see which of
the versions are straight out of the
comics and which are sort of people that
he's basing on real-life tropes so what
will happen tonight is his I'll post a
video explaining the Smallville
arrowverse crossover because of what
they did on Supergirl last night that's
a pretty cool thing that they did people
were asking me about it while I was at
the Justice League premiere but while
you wait for everything you can click
here for my non-spoilery Justice League
reaction video and you can click here to
listen to the cast talk about the big
characters they want to have in the
sequel thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight